لعلك تبعت المشاهد التي كنا نبث وحصلت
عليها الجزيره ل معارك من المسافه صفر بين
كتائب القسام وقوات الاحتلال في حي الدرج
و حي التفاح ما الذي استوقف في هذه
المشاهد حسن هناك عده امور في هذا الاطار
او من هذه الفيديوهات
اولا القتال في حي التفاح والدرج هذا
الامر بالعقل الاسرائيلي حسب ما تقول
اسرائيل انها انتقلت الى مرحله السيطره
عليه وهذا الامر لم يحصل اما مرحله
التنظيف كما تقول اسرائيل هو في الشجاعيه
وهذا ايضا وهذا ايضا لم يحصل والدليل على
ذلك هذا القتال من المسافه السفريه ولكن
الشيء الجديد حسن هو استكمال اطلاق
الصواريخ من شمال غزه والذي من الضروره
وحسب الواقع والادعاءات الاسرائيليه انها
انتهت منه فاذا كلما تقدم الجيش
الاسرائيلي في مكان تعيده المقاومه الى
المربع الاول وهذا يعطي او يفرض قلق وهبوط
في المعنويات للعسكري الذي يريد ان يحقق
شيء وقد يضع اي يعني ضغطات كثيره على
المستوى
السياسي ماذا يعني هنا اطلاق الصوا
من شمال غزه باتجاه الاراضي المحتله كما
تقول كتائب القسام بالعلم العسكري بوجود
قوات الاحتلال داخل منطقه تقول انها توغلت
فيها وسيطرت عليها وفجاه تطلق الصواريخ من
داخل هذه
المنطقه اطلاق الصواريخ وهذا تخمين هو
ايضا عبر الانفاق يعني هناك فتوحات معينه
قادره ان تصل اليها المقاومه لا تزال لا
تعرفها القوات الاسرائيليه بالرغم من
تواجدها في هذه المنطقه هي قادره على نقل
هذه الذخيره الثقيله هذه اللوجستيه
الثقيله وبالتالي القدره على اطلاق هذه
الصواريخ
والاختفاء وعدم القدره على الرد
الاسرائيلي هذا الامر يعطي عامل المفاجاه
الاساسي يعني عامل المفاجاه ان كان داخل
المدن الاهله حسن او حتى في الاماكن
المفتوحه عمل مفاجاه لا يزال بيد المقاومه
طيب هنا اي تحدي يفرضه هذا الواقع على
قوات الاحتلال
يعني هذا ربما يجعلنا نقول بان السيطره
على كل قطاع غزه والتوغل في كل قطاع غزه
عمليا لن يمنع اي مشاهد الالتحام التي
نتابعها يوميا ولن ولن يمنع مع اطلاق
الصواريخ من اي منطقه في غزه باتجاه
الاراضي المحتله كما تقول
القسام هو القلق الاسرائيلي حسن من
الانفاق يعني اليوم عرض على انه نفق
للقياده في حماس السنوار طيب نحن نتعجب
هذا امر طبيعي هذه هي نقطه قوه المقاومه
يعني المقاومه نظمت قتالها في حال الهجوم
عليها على قطاع غزه على ثلاث مستويات
الاماكن الفارغه او المفتوحه من هنا تفجير
حقل الالغام في البريج اثنين القتال على
تخوم المدن وبالتالي القتال داخل المدن
بالاضافه الى الانفاق هذه منظومه كامله
متكامله لا تزال تعمل وهذا امر مقلق جدا
للقياده الاسرائيليه العسكريه كما
السياسيه حسن كان البعض يفترض بان هذه
الانفاق هي انفاق ممتده
ومتصله بعضها
ببعض لكن على ما يبدو من خلال ما نشاهد
حتى ما يعلنه الجيش الاسرائيلي ان هذه
الانفاق ليست متصله ببعضها البعض هل يعني
ذلك بان اكتشاف نفق او فتحه نفق مهما كان
كبيرا وممتدا لا يعني ابدا اكتشاف الانفاق
التي تعمل منها المق
مفهوم الانفاق حسن هو ايضا له حمايه يعني
له هندسه معينه يخدم منظومه عسكريه
واستراتيجيه عسكريه وحتى تكتيكيه معينه
منها ما هو للقياده منها ما هو للقيام
بكمائن في مكان ما وهذا ما يحصل في جحر
الديك وحتى في معبر ارتس او بيت حنون فاذا
لكل من هذه الانفاق هدف معين ال البعض
يقارنها
بالانفاق بالستينات والسبعينات في فيتنام
هذا امر خاطئ في فيتنام كانت للاختباء فقط
في غزه هي للقتال للوجستيات دريب للمنامه
وبالتالي لاطاله عمر الحرب